here's the next story
it's from barclays it's called how to
manage financial differences as a couple
exclusive tips from barclays you know
everyone exclusive exclusive exclusive
not that exclusive you already put on
the web buddy anyway
it goes on to say managing financial
differences as a couple can be a
challenge yes i agree and can place a
strain on the relationship so to help
here to help
they've employed dr peter brooks he's
the head of behavioral finance at
barclays we talked about
when it comes to financial wellness and
your finance it's 20 mental 80
behavioral what you actually do so it's
actually pretty interesting dr brooks is
the head of behavioral finance at
barclays major major major bank
financial institution and he's put
together five
exclusive tips for managing financial
differences as a couple are you ready
for these five tips david vanessa i know
vanessa's in a relationship yeah my
parents on the phone yeah
okay so here's number one
here's number one consider how to split
joint expenses let's get into it they
say the article says when it comes to
your joint bills it's important to both
be on the same page yeah no [ __ ] but you
got to feel comfortable with how you're
paying for these bills think about how
you will split
the expenses in a way that you both
feel is fair split
comfortable
fair keywords there it's not always
necessary but having a joint account for
your bills can give you both both a
sense of confidence control and fairness
so that's number one consider
how to split joint expenses you guys
live together you're dating how do you
want to do this let's talk it out yeah
number two set spending boundaries on
essentials essentials are things you
just can't live without so this
couple this is for couples that live
together specifically all right so for
example they may involve having the
central
air or central ac or the ac heating
central heating or ac on a on less or
lower you know girls are always cold i'm
so cold oh my god it's so cold out there
maybe you don't make it so cold in the
house maybe make it warmer you figure
that out you know split the difference
or you figure oh bathroom time what the
hell is my girl doing in the bathroom
for an hour and a half it's crazy right
the shower's running this had all of
these issues all these differences right
can we get out of the shower we got to
be there at eight o'clock and it's 7 15
and you just got in the shower and we
need to take an hour's shower and our
water bill is like ridiculous this month
okay or maybe you're just choosing a
house that you guys can both afford so
that's what's inside of this shower
together
together bang bang bang bang bang shout
out to bang energy to sponsor the show
thank you
so you spent you set spending boundaries
on essentials all right i see one guy
andres hernandez
just yells sex sex sex
one day andres you're going to have it
and it's going to be great i promise you
number three
create a fun fun speaking of songs
create a fun fund so the advice is this
involves you and you involves you both
contributing an agreed amount of money
to fund each week or month allowing you
to enjoy fun together without feeling as
though one is reliant upon the other i.e
date night how we doing date night every
week every couple should have a date
night saturday night me and you baby
girl it's date night we're getting
wasted we're pulling up trading apps
we're gonna make duis all day long it's
date night me and robin hood baby you me
and robin hood okay
create a fun fun cool i get that fun fun
say that three times fun fun fun fun fun
things fun fun you know you know the you
know the first three letters in fund
fun
okay get out number four
david's killing it with the cha-ching
number four set a gift budget by
agreeing to a budget you can ensure that
neither party feels guilty for spending
too much or too little when it comes to
gifts and if they want to surprise you a
little something something something
extra
you know yeah you you know that this
doesn't come without the pressure with
the pressure of expecting something
similar return all right cool so you set
a gift budget look babe for valentine's
day 200 bucks that's to do don't go too
crazy we're gonna do more all right
anniversary 500 bucks birthday you know
look
um
so set a gift budget number five again
this is from barclays have monthly
check-in days all right what does this
mean communicating regularly about your
finances is part of the game
communicating this is your opportunity
to talk about anything that is on your
mind sunday it's check-in day yeah how'd
we do this week where we at kind of
spent too much money at the borders ah
you know we actually did good we stayed
in we netflix and chilled it's all good
it's all good are we collectively saving
for something look i know that we're not
going out for the whole month because
months from now we're going to the
bahamas baby we're doing it all right
yeah so we're communicating we're having
monthly check-ins we're talking so you
know they if you google like top issues
in relationships top of the list is
communication and money everyone's
fighting arguing about you don't talk
enough you talk too much you don't hear
me you don't listen you know you've got
the money for this
communicate so what's the bottom line
communicate
about
money
right so
here's my little you know at the end of
each segment i'd like to kind of give
you uh my little my tips paul garcia has
one last tip uh don't have a kid
hey you know
don't get a kid eventually maybe you do
though all right
um
so money is one of the top issues
relationships we get it communicate
communicate like so i'm old school and i
tend to date girls that don't make as
much as me no disrespect to them so i'll
always
um
pay more than them like if it's
valentine's day i'm gonna treat them
well i'm gonna get them maybe they get
me something nice i'm not expecting an
even exchange i'm not having
these types of or a gift budget what it
is what it is but maybe so you don't
necessarily agree with that one i'm just
saying you know it all depends on your
financial situation if you and your girl
are both making 50 grand a year exactly
and you're both are living together and
you guys are splitting around all right
like
you know let's talk it out what what
seems fair so for me
what i don't like is basically
doing nothing for the girl to do nothing
i said look maybe i pay the rent but you
take care of the groceries sure maybe i
pay the rent you pay utilities whatever
it is but you
doing nothing while i work pay all the
bills get all the groceries pay the
utility bills and you're just like
chilling that doesn't necessarily add up
believe me i've had those types of
relationships they don't work out in the
end so obviously you got to pay your
fair share but basically you talk it out
you work it out you come to an agreement
that's the most important thing some
people say i don't want to talk to my
girl about this i don't want to i want
to talk to my girl period
[Laughter]
you got to pay your fair share
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broke